[music]
in the last two rounds of the St. Field Cup
Magnus Carson did the impossible
lagging behind the leaders, he
won the last two games and Nastya
where the treatment that had to be white
draw against the Mamedyars
the rest of the pursuers 1 but failed
succeed in the last round and
now in the role of spectators will follow
enthralling that break for the right
raise the main trophy over your head
tournament in st louis cup 1 700 not
skip the tiebreak starts right
now
[music]
good afternoon, miss you
still Evgeny Miroshnichenko and the world
Skripchenko and is waiting for us today
good day to you
dear friends, but it was not clear before
is the end of the working day today and
after all, Magnus succeeded, that is
fantastic two wins at the finish line
such yes of course with the help of rivals but
nevertheless, he must be given credit
Yes, I didn’t give up after nine
draws in a row and achieved this
interruptions which we will watch
today let's see again
the final table of the single cab tournament is here
the first number here we have can
c actually i didn't even check
frankly additional indicators
because it doesn't really matter
equals
tie-break is played magnus carlsen henry
they share first place third
fourth for karjakin and anand then
four people at 50 percent
perhaps the most unlucky 1st time
you can call me on not remembering, well, he
of course he did a lot
good and in a bad way for that
to be 50 percent
three wins i'm on and 3a poorest losses
and the last divided you forests or out
Aronian, of course, this one cannot be included in the asset
tournament well, the chances still remain for me
it seems to him if at the lemon they still have to play
rapid chess in november so more
can qualify for the final table and
we have, as I understand it, an interruption today
does not affect the location of the place in the grand
round in the overall standings yes because the points
shared here we look so we are in the lead
magnus carlsson and apparently already wins in
grunge pre-selection from tour already
no one seems to me to catch up with him alone
we lie with very good chances because
that he played only three tournaments for him both
rapido play yes and
Levon Aronian is not in the fourth position
share see huge share 4
features on the sixth position of the Aronian pocket and
Karjakin is curious
that's a point behind everything, I don't remember
that is the last
rapid will actually be a lot
decide yes for these chess players
there everything is very close and in if sony
lost hope in which too
the last tournament is generally very
very interesting little technical defecation
twins in Russian I will say what happens
now our stream i so goes in both
channels and in Russian and English
of course it's a bit confusing
confused the cards so what up the prize idea
prize money that were on the last
the chart is not yet updated so
say because I will remind you in a tie-break
played out here we are almost the entire tournament i
said that the money is equally divided in fact it is
in fact, some part
prize pool for first second place
will be played in today's toi
breakin to simplify
I'll tell the math what the winner gets
15 thousand dollars more, that is
so-so
match rapid in one day for 15 thousand is
more than say lebanon earlier he
got over mr not given it seems to me
what should be encouraged the winners of the tournament and
poradnik
here in tournaments the first place in money
the reward is not divided at all
you are not so strong let's look at the format
today's tie-break remind again
yes, that is, the match is played semi-fast
chess before the round-robin tournament in us
it turned out although there were chances if
won karjakin yes yesterday he had
an extra pawn against Fabiano Caruana and
Sergey had some chances to win
certainly well failed therefore
a match is played between a quality united
25 minutes plus 10 seconds delay in
case of equality, well, respectively
in the event of a draw in the match in the event of a score of 11
Potentially 3 sets of blitz are played
matches, that is, going to two parties in
blitz
five minutes plus 3 seconds delay if
11 tons one more such blitz and one more
such a blitz after which it is a total total of 8
games if, according to the results of eight games
there will be a draw, then the chief judge will accept
the solution has already been discussed on the sidelines
that the referee is set up to hold such a thorma
gi don partire da you probably don't
it will be like last year they both
declared winners yes most likely
will play will play until the victory until the final
I think Magnus wants so much
it's easy to win this tournament
strangle sitting
will be general to announce so it will come
not only norma getas can be a friend
I apply to I don't know
as far as magnus bloody one in this
I mean yes, I understand what it is
historical absolutely will be events we
accustomed to magnus
as a master of combos, well, not this year
because this year he has everything
he did well in all tournaments
won with a margin besides the very one here
quick tournament here st louis
which preceded the cup single yes where
magus did not work out so well
beamed after won fingers after
yesterday's won fingers and so
nice to see
real emotions real joy
so today's match is very interesting
we welcome all chat you can to
us join too on a grant hour tour
.
hayk and evgeniy say hello to you
teaching student composite
but it seems to me essentially forced to go in
sb5 variant
elephant 2 is trying to pick up on foot
because otherwise White wins back on c4
we get the usual so nice
Catalan version has a cult hunt md5
if I'm not mistaken yes here
funny idea to take on 3 first again
win the game before attacking the knight immediately
and rook h1 anaconda 5 white at the very
what are called do not pay attention
go still elephant same 2 and short
castling is done, well, in general, this
quite interesting and enough
interesting development from h1 walks
the knight on d7 i.e. the pawn on c4 is given away
horses are playing bt-7 but now I don’t see
reasons why white should not take on
c4 and I suspect that some small
outweighed should white get nbc4
played and b5 or something at once
it seems to me that the day was set to play
in dominoes this game in such a positional
you will recognize the keys at least 3 of it most likely
a little surprised how he wants to continue
that's right, let's think about it now
where whites go to them because the book
3 is still very strange
cage for a horse yes he actually and a pawn
their own 2 stops and an elephant
c1 lock the meeting no 3 sooner rather than later
good but now Magnus is just walking to
her 5 on that ding hits pretty fast on
e5 beats on d1 the king of trouble is one
interesting
king before 1 game i rather expected candy
one so that later and at 4 somehow not
lose the right castling role to 1 in
the first pawn sacrifice after the knight is already 4 yes
again, this is quite rare.
because often white moves away vd2 and
kuni 3 after b5 yes go 5 knight where
is yours
Daniel used the house of and here
interesting, yes, we know that he didn’t play
played invited Magnus Daniel to the training camp
yes, before the match and, accordingly, completely
it is likely that here is a tribute somehow
participated in the analysis
this option what I am what
pretty rare walker not at 35 since
this position is much more often white
calmly play elephant same 2 short and
only then only then prefer
deal with the c4 pawn in one way or another
way most often games are crossed into its
somehow just undermining b2b 3 before after cb
I take queen b3 but playing some
position where by token is a pawn but there is
it is possible to take the center and this is an option yes and
he's also pretty edgy
yes, because they gave it to c4 if 5
do not want to play something a la slang 7
then after it is 2, well, some directory
dreams just turn white white and
clearly enjoys the process
well kanye 5 took took took on d1
here's the first question you can retreat to eating
5 to 3 sim and the most of course
the obvious move is to go for the same 4 and
see what the kv-5 tank will play
so he's 4, I'm trying to figure out which one
the move on the horse 4 is possible, oddly enough
just an elephant 2 bye
because the bit on f2 doesn't seem to be white
takes on c6 White takes on 8 and
then another horse is lost on the h1 date
from probably until the elephant is two and then already
depending on the reaction, let's say bishop b7
maybe king c2 for now yes that is on
b5 hangs somewhere either kanye 4 i.e. we
obviously killed some initiative for a pawn
eat before after knight move d5 must be beaten 5
of course I don’t want to, but wait a minute
why of course not though food probably
yes blacks play
at first i thought cd was probably strong there
e4 vodka from here to 5 food well even here
you have to you have to you have to look you have to
study because it may turn out that
this position is playing let's say a4 and now if
blacks are trying to keep the chain somehow
walk b4 then 4 might be interesting
let's say they took the same elephant 2
if white manages to win back the pawn here i am
so I figured out the option of an elephant and at 5, let's say
as if in 5 rooks 1 to if white is on and 4
are selected in some flank there a little
beaten though there are legends 8 or even 3
0 and will be covered 2 and 3 is located follow
map and actually which was
played this year Rakhmanov Timothy and
finally played of course not 4 smear
played ponyasha in the spirit of you remember Lena
4 knights and when white 15 6
there is a pawn on the hitherto and for the k coupon it
Pretty standard before after
exchanging on e5 is often such a yes to
he jumps on and 5 different 5 and white
looking for access to point 2 6
in one way or another, as well as
universal in catalonia
on the reaction on horseback 45 service sem bye
play it 2 before
he would be 7 elephant 2 but here it is interesting
i.e. black c5 can can and 3 0
play now with the tempo by the way move like
not stupid
so the feeling can be attacked and
all joke small company 3 double
ella grandfathers one mate it is clear what is needed
do something about
about this confrontation between lag d8 and
how can d1 have a bishop on d2 until
strange because the king c2 is a bit off
clumsy knight for 4 checks get to 5
king b1 c65
for now, this is the economy
don't know a 3
here again it is necessary so enough
carefully study the options gave grandfathers 4
probably not a good move isabel
Well, maybe you can just walk away
c6
that is, while hanging on e5, then I’ll finish the outcome
5 should not be
and then let's say f4 black once again
and smoke to them jump at 34 a little
somehow embarrassing, it seems to me the bottom and move 3 0
care castling quite looks
quite harmoniously I suspect of
ours that here on 3 0 still scrapped d2 and
maybe king c1 because rook a
we will try to include by means of a
24 and there is a king after one la grandfathers one
how to get there and how to get there is also very important
will white find a good square for the king
or not, that is, so far none of them like
terrible things to happen on this bunch
can't until
soldier water but no wait 65 black
played 3 0 going to 65 mobiles all
equal to the elephant up to 2 moves it can only
permutation of moves, well, actually we
did until 3 0 and went tapeworm yes that is
maybe here is the question
rather of this property, in principle, black
want to castling long or
they will prefer the flank of the scheme to be short with
the idea of ​​the ladder is to leave this rook on d8
this 98 could be like this
prefer is strategic ones
after a dream, you don’t really need it anyway
change h floor elephants do you think
loss of pace of words 5 no very
wanted the pace i guess while progress h4
often such an idea is the French defense
wait until the black orcs rummages then
4 short elephant same beach
Well, when you come here, you need to look, yes, here and in
6 on look all the same king while in
center
so they show us big and look
dim same so there has been a cat lag
on the clock let's get back to position
which are actually now on our board
yes, this is one of the possibilities
by the way the idea is to care for the elephant before 2 so
to put the elephant on again that he
there will control the field to 8 to
I want to solve the problem of the king and the king
not yet knowing how convenient it is roles red
can immediately king c2 not
another option is here again to me
I like the idea of ​​putting an elephant on
again maybe e3 king e2 but there
need to follow b4 bishop 6 before king
this is also pretty good
smart idea let's say on the neighbor
cow with 2 but well short what to do
on and on until nothing to do until let's say
come out at 4 maybe raise the bishop to f3
so that he is needed there 2 did not sag a day
chose 1 + sony sem play yes probably
it is necessary to undermine the pawn e5 with this end 2
hides 2 and still f6 byd castling
in style and plans 30 and I am also very
like improved by what choice in this
position give is not entirely clear on what
based claims Magnus at the ready
yes, and it seems to me that this opposition
elephant opposition before confrontation
Bishop g2 and Bishop b7 I haven't seen either
one option where it will be in favor
whites but the black hour can say
the simplest such up to 6 took I took
so I understand that some kind of horse jump
with taking on the same 2 is quite entitled to
existence though from another country
sent three took the rook, 1 and white
get on the chains
then but such a question, by the way, takes away
whether black takes a pawn whether black writes
that is, long castling, probably yes, but
probably just castling long yes yes
yes, and here, by the way, here's a sag
this bishop, yes, that is, the knight f6 or even
maybe knights b6 are more accurate and 5 moves
just no yes and 5 moves no because
that hangs like 2 because how is it
such a position she would be enough
interesting conflict of whites is very strong
Black's pawn on d6 would have appeared there
most likely the point on d5 for the knight
but-but-but move e5 is simply impossible
hanging elephant on the same sign 2sa
before 6 so far miscellaneous 6 so far early i.e.
knight c6 can try to organize
after the king c2 put the rook on r1 and
there already look at the find on d6
so Magnus the elephant thinks again
there is still a possibility
king c2 quite a move can be like
it’s not strange to play some kind of elephant and
3 just so he doesn't hang there because
what do kings need to castling
determine when the king needs to stand alone
disgusting what are possible
sequel king c2 we watched from
you to the porch 2 to the most such
understandable most familiar move but honestly
saying it's not clear how you go on
make progress
suppose a short lag hd1 let's say
even if blacks don't want anything yet
the owners are playing there 8 the truth is here
maybe you can try to jump
no, you can't jump e6's knight here
once again we fall under the tactics of Cooney
be four check and service g2 again i
just wanted to get in
and 3 in this position I like you know
jump on four at the end of 29 may
be because here it is probably already possible
consider them 5
because the knight c6 is still a pawn
loses if you take it on the aisle, well
most likely f and maybe out of 5 somewhere
strokes in this position as if in 3
for example in 3 say ft 8.8 and
Moroccans finish
3 at the end when not Quincy third just
will
likely to run out 3 to service 7
honda one elephant c8 get along 8ml clothes
one king king and all I think that a
maybe the king and all me accurate
barrier again by the way, although even there the king
and 8 blacks shouldn't be big
problems, but maybe can be more accurate
so put the rook, I think that
Black people shouldn't have big problems.
there is some date here potentially
Weakness in elephantine you got it
a6 it seems to me that I can’t get to it
should be should be equal well
well we again we have gone very far
from the real position on the board and of course
now to magnus
need to do some enough
a serious choice, yes, if you just attack
on peshkova black
Entrance Fellow One Black Dress Up 1 Well
here is the question again because you are 4
bo2 b3 must be reckoned with and
[music]
well, here's some immediately and pressure on
pawn c literally 3 is simply impossible
my due bc slates one king c1
outweigh k not threatening kuni d6
yes if after well then not really
it is clear how to react, although it may be
this is a game position
there is a king up to 7 in general a new version so
tell developments king dc soap
keeps 8 maybe it's not good
for black it seems all the same
human and must be firmly connected
rooks
probably yes this is one of the approaches
such possible rapid chess as
just play such high quality
strong moves and wait when the enemy
the truth will float one is not like
a person who starts voluntarily
give figures just for that
to beat the dino the only game
which he stood to lose then was
game with anand for the whole tournament
Yes, and passed again in this
positional maneuvering struggle and
he's feeling very comfortable so all the same
he needs these things
specifics for the position
the score for fate seems very good to me
sees love tactically loves and knows how
count the young man here completely
you can't argue with that, well, that's just
talked about what I can at Magnus on
hours overweight, let's say not so much
important would be and now a couple of extra minutes
Dean, that is, Magnus is thinking
is determined but the actual arrangement
on this party, but where is it anyway
put a figure it looks like nothing like that
White people don't really have anything outstanding for me
really interesting whether magnus had a couple
training fingers yesterday with him
is self lead second and [ __ ]
nielsen and
often it is after lasika before
fast to fast
it's very important to warm up
after all, 2510 seems to me like this
improved classic yes but 15 10 or even
10 10
it is not possible that they are with some kind of couple
fast park just to have to
feel the rhythm
feel the rhythm so so what
the rook still goes to t1 to 1, that is
the king stays on d1 yes this is the position
looked decent enough 24 and
case b3 really take she bo3
king dc
Yes, here Magnus is still important for all
their creativity and desire to play
victory is important for the beggar to keep because
what can White play before
to say in an attempt to complicate the fight that
after ti4 do took took the king to 7
I've got the latest version
took the king to 7 though maybe there
cavalry 5 exodus x5 looks like that's if
here coins again then black beat go
knights e3 seems to me to beat on the same 2
come the sun 6 probably just
offer a draw even in this position
do me too far gone and on what
position after when i liked your
idea exiled again can't even
commit you will take the 8th with the king
I don't know what to do and I don't know
now the king to 2 is already given once
connect let's see yourself be 400
word for 4 horse for 4 there already somewhere
appear through lamps 4 though not the most
successful
well, actually I can go down
4 now it's king c2
It may be worth noting here that
hunting kanebo 4 seems to be missing because
took took the knight e6 on the bishop to 6 is
intermediate take it to b7 and to the rook
b8 has an intermediate check on h6 white
win a piece so the knight is 4 checks each
not yet, but the king seems to us on b1
is now directed in this way and
when will the social respond at 0
or a short cow can be in a long one
probably so far yes so far there is nothing here
on line c and no move to 3 but bella
witcher role would one walk king would 8
up somehow hd1 something elena vasina
will succeed in the west of Canada 60 and here and
as if 5 just has much more
it might even make sense to start
worth the outcome instead of the king would be one
it was worth starting them as if 5 well, what
then some sharpness after all we
we will get yes in this party yes here 3 0
plays den
and additional features
with the word g5 or knight 5 appear before
you only need to protect the elephant 2 for now
baidin king
yes, let the king want to play alone
and open camp and get away from these checks on
b4 permanently
and although such a question did not take them 5 games and
Again, I think this idea is so
thematic in this position what it needs
consider but here is 5 before white
it’s not entirely clear what to do or whether the horse
g5 try given then maybe something even
and sag
if I beat, I honestly suspect that
the horse is the most successful because the most
forcing move is necessary 2 the bishop is hanging but not
I want, I don't want, yes
well, where do the cavalry 3 go to lose
figure, that is, he is 5, yes, how
let's try to fly what to get there
radiation can still be played here
knight c3 that's what confuses me a little and
because it sags like d2 then
the feeling that you have to beat the elephant with an elephant
beats the same 2 even before
attacked the rook on the channel hold one
g5 servants attacked another lag there yet
somehow it keeps me there without haste
it seems hd1 is playing i can handle it on d1
also logical in one order or another
these moves must be made
decides that you can leave the king on t2
maybe this is what it means
there is a king while on t2 there is an elephant somewhere
again
and go look up to 6
maybe I liked it under f5 what is changed
hopes day as if up to 2 does not hang then
eat 10 in 5 son and jujewan with tempo
let's call g2 in some places let's say
horse by 4, something like this can be
that is, white beats black beats on the same 5
attacking the rook ca1 as if 2 hangs
that is, it is necessary to exchange this
in my opinion ohio here is the move f4 is
By the way, it may turn out to be very
a serious problem for black because
that the layer of the elephant has to walk on 6 and
white here iceland 6 have a move in common
elephant cut down of course continuous
the time may even be as much as 24 while they can
matchmakers 6 i like to save more
lags and then battery 4 quickly undermine
as long as the elephant is locked at 61 you wish
I went looking for it seems to me in this version
it is already possible well that the end of 5 asked
most fundamentally not and of course that
same do here it's the same 5 before
bishop g5 how to defend you know i can
played the horse before 66 honda 6 what's the elephant
took
beats a pawn on the soul become a foot donates
pawn until the end is not clear why
i.e. how serious is this
try talagi a beats day to 2b no
slambed d5 our can immediately simplifies that
Is he just trying to make a draw?
a feeling that yes you know took on
d5 i.e. Black has an extra pawn, so
some chance of winning I think
us pawns all 1 of 6
yes, it’s clear that a bunch and more, but
good lans were taken away here you need to understand
where where does the white elephant go at four or and
channel b 44 of the end of the 3rd I'm not very afraid yes
I just can't because of the sunny no
I thought maybe so words 4 bye
maybe you still have to 0
more precisely, White still has to f31 before
hide course match i like you 4
that is, all the extra pawn here it is here
pawn c to which is very difficult
imagine how she actually comes
movement seems to me that just close to
rays
but nevertheless did not work out debut
Magnus, that is, for sure
it can be said that black do not risk not
what white still has to work for
to prove that there are no problems
no really
and then put three or five yeah well
probably yes probably f-35 maybe
water to 2 until yes i.e. e4 we go
like f4 so that i.e. black should
probably somehow the king would sit down clothes
one king c6 to be protected there
potentially they bypassed here here I am
there is no e4 because chess is beating and
45 and then you may not be in time because
that he will be the sun tristan e.p.
we didn't take it seriously
taking food takes food because it's good
but up to 4, that is, no one will give him
play yes most likely slates 3
the sun will follow 3 rooks hi8 e3 g3 it
g5 I think it's a very important move here.
because if white is allowed to put h4
this is such a very compact position, but
same 5 now s4 still connected with sparks
the same lines and a detached pawn right up to
and the blacks inherent on occasion threaten
either 4 rook 6 or even immediately rook
6 that is, such a switch for 6 for me
seems like 5 moves are enough
fundamentally here and in one actually and
does
I can probably still have to experience here
unpleasant minutes to 4 row 4 can be
well then, oh, on the move 4 probably
there is a move made yes immediately
asking such a question that either we are here
closed the kingside and on the queenside
I will not lose most likely yes or after
taking rook 4 hanging our 7 and 2 our it
it was a nike emergency idea but you saw it
of course where it looks like here I am
just looked at some point that's before
4 to breakouts and by the way maybe here
breakthrough to 4 bishop same two will put i.e.
now whites have potential there
an extra pawn on the jig pawn h can
be dangerous there water and 6 boat 6
she can't just catch up owns and 4
Magnus plays and 4 of course the move is
counterintuitive to him nonetheless
interesting interesting to consider means
our 4 4 is possible
these here h1gh one can then get along
And
and now this boat can not be removed because
what up to 4 materials and of course accounted for
walk under the lags
h2 rooks and 4 are also big problems
pawn h3 survives quite simply ram 14
tasot good too possession 4 before
overlap 4
block 4 Odessa problem with Magnus
problems doomed serious such that not
woke up to the end
comment hard to play then
as far as asked what really in the first
parties
stumble world champion look like u
finished cutting I stand on just driving we'll get there
here I am 2 d1 but then audi a6's
the planned scheme will give them nothing
hold the h-pawn
let's think about it here
How scary is this one
position with a torn off pawn to h4 a
wait, maybe you know how to move
make me right that he's not really
aesthetically pleasing 6 now play
h4 and
next what if yes so far true
white is not threatened to take yes well
suppose black needs to react
it's hard to understand how much black needs
you can even react
move there harold family from black beat up
then maybe we should have four
immediately we beat and there is a case of dj cases I beat
youth 4 it must be a draw
still multi-colored and only one extra
pawn wield one question from the horn
here I h1 can play if I'm not there for you
go like 4 4 ​​now white has time
take our 3 and i think now
fundamentally all the same become a rook on 6
after h4 try this tension
somehow use it to your advantage
in a completely unexpected way, we
fighting for a draw with white
yes who could who could expect but already
to already such wonders wonders of combos from
Magnus was already waiting for that in the playoffs
of course, yes, it will demonstrate all the power, but
till
show it doesn't look like that yet
rather udino some chances we
may not really be
woke up need
come to your senses turn on the brain and
completely he took on completely
the right decision to take on 2 5 so father and
he believes that so wait for someone to protect
there is such a move there is such a move
which can lead to some problems
or even the rook 6 h4 is now at 4
because here is a bunch and well, let's say
to capture on f4 so there are different
darkening anger I thought that here somehow
with a check on you barely logged 12 then
no, that is, now I am now allowed
taken away
now for the right
some trouble
that water and two is-3 can something like this
I think you need to tear these pawns at least
once one well even took took la
you hold 6 the truth is probably possible here
already pick up trying islam and 5 somehow
to protect my well, that is, I'm trying
what i'm trying to do for blacks somehow
balance the structure so that black
potentially there were 2 checkpoints, yes, because
which is clear that 1 is superfluous here at
colorful elephants are not enough yes that is
you need at least 2 passes, that is
somehow try
slightly structure to break decoding
I think I wanted to convey everything to us
during the break between games perhaps
study samara xing please stay
with us it
very interesting event before the studio b by
he never gave an interview to mine
Russian-speaking brother caste
so you will have the opportunity
look at this amazing
man and yes maybe succeed him
ask if what brought him to the ball before
Cause there's enough
curious stories yes that's how I
I remember at some point I saw Bobby
fisher did not fly you on the same plane
ruiz somewhere and far, far eugène
de niro also said very interesting
the story is that when they are with him
met they played a couple of fingers
chess she even beat him
said she couldn't do it anymore
so well, what did one think after h10 lag
apparently felt that there is a chance
realistic yes and now we need something
do something like that and once again rook
6 h4 but show white they don't move
nowhere, that is, maybe here just
be like here let's say site king d 7
it’s not entirely clear what whites are doing
useful though you probably need early
or it's too late to go a3 to this thing
didn't even move four jokes
yes, yes, and blacks continue there
cow 6 maybe yes i honestly
I don't even know where I want to go
this king, but they say explicit 6 is acceptable
is more active than on cirrus
she's king dc can be on king to 7
it was worth considering this for taking
well, suppose the pawn is really spoons or
closet up to them store opportunities in 4 to go
what is connected
so yes here you know after after after
breathing was embarrassing here is the move of the elephant 73
today h5 something like you can like 6 yes and
you find out so say what's there
going on royal ass same 7
say hold 6 gone on d4
from this is our real chance and from scientists and
buckwheat positions would certainly help from
a little but well it depends call me again
big let's see let's see bye ladino
boards
draw do not so appetizing owns
4d they can't even send a separate life there
Yes, not bad, I don't even see that
I see, but intellectually, as it is
it's intuitive intelligent doesn't have
no one's attitude to intelligence is better here
this particular position here is white on white
black on black therefore yes no but this
intuitively want to take them and leave
here is the object for attacking the f2 pawn, yes, I understand
which will be very difficult to hold again
be 40 characters have an elephant same 7 well
then it even seemed so simple, yes, and
producer but became here 404 have to
close the flank then probably yes
the main thing is not standing on one flank very much
it will be difficult to break through a3 a5 on the other
hand and the elephant beats about this while too
nothing outstanding gold 6th diabetes 2
yes it's true here the sun is 5 to boat 25
like 3 king b1
What do you need to be careful
lead exactly the fifth floor is entitled to
existence, well, it looks like you know
it seems that somewhere here and I will have to
judge on e4 because other reasonable
options are not so good
yes, so far I have played three from 3, well, just
to somewhere in the options getting along rush
did not sag and the dean makes a decision
close the position personally 5 already
4 walks well, now it remains only to understand
how best to defend against
I suspect that it might even
4 here is such a fence complete
build already
maybe it's worth taking away ladies h1
pre same 4 while magus now takes
on and 4 in fact yes, but only there on 7 not
hanging on
that I'm drunk yes yes the fairy of the night is not at all about
than to speak
well, what else will we fight buckshot not
ended
run you like water h5 bring wine
and sleep it positions
well, gradually to gradually then
eat
I would like to bring it back, of course, but
the simplest king c7 runs into
salon
you mean black at all again not
will be able to eat I don’t see how to spend
again you need to bring and first yes yes
transfer the rook somewhere to play on
that flank play h5 in an understandable way i
I think it's still white stupidity
the perimeter is still quite large
pawn in 2 hold and need to hold photo
75 that would be 4 suits goes yes this
now I’m already sleeping a serious application just for
then to build a fortress before
I suspect that black needs to beat on
pass otherwise otherwise do not break through cb
king would 3 well and something to portray here
Olya here are the logs from owner 6 owners 4
here after we say sent to get dressed 6
the question is whether white h5 needs to play what
one side entrance
attractive rook there lets
lift along the line along the line but with
the other may somewhere just turn out to be
we’ll lose a pawn, yes, but if not cb, then
I honestly don't really see where where
break through it looks like it will build successfully
-
picket fence and party finished rook 6
playing ding ding here decided that decided that
beat the unnecessary dias 6 but what is the king
b2 h5 it looks like quite a draw logged and
one king i 6 water to 2 yes and magnus
you can see how much
faster Magnus played the sun 6 so what
And
elephant up to 4 and not surprised there is just scrapped
would sem den answer servants 8 years after all
where do you yourself go from some to
this if there is no it's all over
up repeat repeat moves first
tie-break party ends in it
not that it directly means ran away to a draw
but I had some problems just can
had just magnus carlsson with you
was not curious to look at
stats go between ding and could
sama taemin agro paidi there seems to be a day
not left. well let's see it is
now the second batch will start
there in ten minutes maybe a little
later judah will be white color we are now
going for a little break
prepare like yes indeed
seems to be suitable for Lexin field studio
stay with us until we continue to follow
behind that break in just a few
minutes
[music]
[applause]
not everywhere their rights to the motorcycle anus ad
blitz
world of the lobby
igr-100 ended up with a lease with every yuzik the
game + distance to our blues museums 1 oh
to have clearly on you and blueberry
dodecanese the blues drop
complex by someone from about the secret
from the floor the tongue was fused in an hour and the mother
[music]
good afternoon with us in the studio famous
vocabulary
sochi put quietly in the final
finally he appeared in our studio
studios would be in Russian on Russian air and
I would like to ask him a question
the most obvious how did he come to
chess in export without end
exhibits want the end gave dubches
Assembly Hall
better sausage for transfer again yours to him
always liked chess but he learned
only taught him to play at the age of 13
uncle fred but played along for the second time
fingers an hour here infa dear nikolaevich
but in fact rex is always
was interested in chess he played at school
then maintained this interest in the game and
during university he even
started playing stream tournaments from the third
played his first round of nervous
parties already when he had children
eighty-fifth year he is no longer so
it was easy to participate in tournaments
write-write crazy from like first
master world space
Of course, everyone remembers Bobby's mother
now Easter
in America there was such a great interest in
this match, eric followed him as well as
the whole world
come in decided killed the landing you now
sex 18 fox studios.
and already, the kind of dog's eyes
another site is accused of a cup wide
cartoon url page space
admits after just finished
their professional 10 activities in
investment bank
I don't even know how to translate this into
Russian he
he had dinner in 2006 with two
partners and he thought it would be about
art but in reality
we were talking about chess and literally on
the next day they he he express well
let's see where we are
found a chess club and like this
way to the chess club
they found buildings and
it was created in san luis and the news
from learn to drive a historian
to any sex of donkeys muradyan traditions and
romance from the block or humanly no
4 used unfortunately yes yes
grate I got the heads up
said that almost all
projects related to chess
chess club were very successful
it was very important for him that the club
located near city schools
devote a lot of time to chess
education schools and
[music]
I think he himself is surprised that everything
passes 40 m2 so well
important events judge your will be
plain meat on sight today will be like this
a little unusual event in evgeniy you
Uchi already said this - Eric will sit down for
board
will hit 1 rubber band
rex called garry kasparov today
and told him such sad news that
he will have to play with him for the team
yes, I'll go harry kimovich of course
supported said that everything will be fine I
you file furniture kid you bastard
booth and another hour model
from fabia hemp
ai fly fisherman hour means harry
kimovich
watch the board and play a match with fabiano
caruana and besides and he thinks that harry
Of course it will not be easy in this match, but
we look im very happy that he
chess returns even like this
unusual role
often said by the game starts in case
of a its worthy mind and like they
like 5 white snow sheep eisenberg and
quotes I leave a dialogue with every
place for blanc de blanc are you a part of
that's not entirely fair, of course.
identify the winners of the classic
tournament that's it in quick or persons and
he talked about it with magnus' father
carlsen and
with Garry Kasparov, he gives such
a little analogy if
jogging stands near kwan
online yes if you are so you then
reveal the winner, for example
athletics in athletics
run juice will 8 likes you ft fts
optima still life school jai
4 believe that it is necessary to identify
the winners are still in the classic
format to hold a match of two or
four finger holmes
stripped off
almost likes and dined sempai because sample
it is his brush of paris of ages industry
mean especially for for the match on
world championship cancer think what you need
more fingers at even 1418
and at some point in fact if
turns out to be a draw just to announce two
players champions
this is his opinion I died yet
extracts from the evaluation and we will return to us
literally in a minute in a couple of minutes
.
[music]
well
so back to that break for the title
cup winner sen hele yes yes here himself
Lexin field market visited our studio
the second batch starts like me
wanted
the winner today will be the winner before
determined yet in quick and blitz
yes, the second part begins
literally at any moment, I understand
the second game will start 1 with white
wait in rapid, that's just hung
the poster of the tournament hung there in the background
st louis pedan blitz 9 to 15 which
passed there let me remind you that Dean beat Magnus
white pieces what will happen which
there will be a directory or up to 4 knight f6 4 and 6 same
3d 5 please and elephant 2 magnus
immediately takes on c4, I wonder what
still mean world champion
because after the knight f3 you can
quite calmly go to what there
really exiled 7 but you can try this
hold the pawn with a6 or c6
except for the knight f3, as I understand it especially
white has nothing to do there is some step
so4 with a queen, that is, with a knight on the same
one but there, in my opinion, blacks are all right
in a dream only aksa 4 gives
here another retell it seems to me
zenki, that is, does not want this pawn to be sacrificed
even even temporarily even time yes and now
here after queen 4 but is in quotation marks
normal strokes up to cub up to 7 face heart
6 have i think move funds sims ideas
slate 6 play knight f3 knight d7
and it looks a little strange but
there is such a system
there doesn't seem to be anything too terrible
there are no blacks and then black somehow
tries e5 let's see how
Magnus will react interestingly to step so4
what are you left and options yes
people play and still no backbone
theory attempt surprise element especially
in rapid, that is, rapid chess is very
it is important to find out what Magnus has prepared and there
in this position for whom to be nothing
you know sometimes i think
that's for fast for blitz what we are
overestimate the preparation, that is, understandably
that they are very ready in the opening in general
so to speak yes a lot of time
give the debut but I won't be surprised if here in
the decision necessarily c4 was so slightly
impulsive yes because he knew
let's say this option is
plans to do after knight f3 yes and by
ties 4 well conceived the narrowest bdsm
plays white takes on c4
a6
well, yes, topic 6 servants three pretty quickly
check if magnus had a visit in this
debut
such a woman of course no it wasn’t very
often defends this position Vishy Anand
you black servants walk like d6 I plan
probably somewhere e5 and knight h3 its like
interesting ponyash 3 and fast dance
played that is apparently it
this arrangement is familiar to him
she's on a big diagonal before open
castling castling but like this
really not a standard position
our three black knights can play e5 me
it seems pretty calm here either
yet
to be patient until it will be a conditional move then younger
would you anally worth providing such
lookin weird looking here's an e3 bishop
directed against c5 even the first turn
expect of course is all c5
follow play again call
respect of course a little clumsy
right hand in my there ti5 is
basic
ok black can queens sims play
I still hint at c75, but in the case
get along one which c5 prevent
then already switch to plan light and
after e5 the knight on h3 stands a little bit
clumsily
if white does not plan to capture on and 5 a
if give this pony and 5 with the pace and too
again, black should have everything in
OK, I think objectively
problems of the world champion will not arise
should but of course imagine how
black this position play to win too
very difficult, so it is possible that
we will be waiting for the continuation of the tie-break
one party you world in the base on this
position after mutual shorts
castling which
black would continue the water 8
I know how much this one I can judge
makes sense
d5 at first i 2 as I understand it and
now still have to go lags would
8 she will come to bed and dress the mogu
play the strange move h7 h6 until
I define the situation before and propose
invite white to speak blitz like this
at the highest level in this position after
Bishop before 6 whites without herself from the woods played in
sc2 version 2 went found sonechka not
hatch and he seems to yard picking
went to her h3 e5 composition permutations a
is it necessary to get such a position but this
what was it if soda gave a blitz poll
moreover, the Internet blitz site is an hour here and
pocket she's here too interesting again
glows 220 and what is our 35 this is
played yes to destroy c4 delivering
use a nazi 4 i.e. after move h6 if
white let's play heart 2 date
managed to get a position not with a move and 5
how can they go to it because
again and look of course longer game
used to play a6 and what not so much
useful moves and what he wants to wait
queen c2 know you snowdrift by about these
party and just go on
move to the position of which was analyzed
at least he knows well if whites have
for a long time there are whites now another photo
let's say there is a possibility somehow
try up to get a fresh stance it
closing 30 trilogy thought walks like
queen and one, as usual, such a positive
to give the elephant on a pole to our
this is probably not correct
idea in that position therefore yes all the same
there the figure somehow killed them not quite
don't want to donate even in catalonia
you can't go against yourself anyway
so what should you do
black now that is the choice after all
either play the idea with bmb 5 rook would 8
service sem up either try e5 forecast
somehow use that the fact that
the queen remains on .
well, let's say btr-3 most likely I would give
you will have a heart 5 don't mind black
probably play a4 a4 yes probably 44 to
stupid skate 4 let's go then the truth again
played ether 8 to fierce tula would be two
Black must play the mode 8 so
less yes and here is konev 4 what are you doing again
it seems to be possible it seems to be possible c5 and it is necessary
on and most likely should beat coins and 5
and here it may mean these
here are the Catalan games from the capture do not give and
with a horse for 2 3 yes maybe right away
coin d3 and let's say b6 is scrapped
quite unpleasant for me
picking points from 24 at once
straining the d5-pawn, that is, black can
be must on and simon step and by the way
even
even here a4 these are the positions before
suppose if black would play 4 there
they change horses
not that she killed something serious, but
it's a bit unpleasant to play as black
White has such a compact position, the knight should
three there like I'm in 300 that recede
there are positions for both rooks at once
black a little bit that's how it is again for
rapid chess this position of course
prefer white edges to play better
easier and than we always have to
solve specific issues on trifles, but
it's good good what does black have
no alternatives conditionally speaking service 7
play up as an alternative move
service to this yes, well, that is, they won’t score
whites can be beaten so that it would be water
everyone so awkwardly stood up to some move
from general considerations there fd1 while a
because I don’t really understand where the horse is
she goes to lie on 5 horses to put
on 4 to fix the a6-pawn for me
mace appears 4
here a strange one may arise, see here
conditional queen 8 to 4 lags about the squad here
so in the Spanish game then the rook by 5 to
that is, she attacks the pawn again and
somewhere can even switch somewhere
on the queenside, that is, this one here
the game is such a double edged fun but
Here is Magnus and the Bassem elephant walks, yes, that's all
still doesn't want to play off saying goodbye
asymmetric structure wants somehow
a little
groove body because you know here I am after all
thought to take take until you go a4
let's say play fd1 and here at black
it is not clear what they should do
number can be anywhere up to 4 to 5
smoothie me go angry physics heart
yeah well, now let's say up to 5 numbers 2
more often and 5 on the same 2 it will not be clear further
unlock just repent 5 owners 8
divisible 8 x 6 can hold nothing and not
there I end up 4 somehow sneaking on f5 and
until there is a move by the same 6 that is
some kind of game, maybe not just
Same Huge School Same 2
just go date yourself office lady kunis 4
on ft it’s okay to beat the husband with whites
on the bass, in fact, I also need
bring and 420 kn to 30 to 3 fingers
move c5 good either service today
bead feeling that you need to take on
pool yes here could be here honda 3 yet
stop c5 yes again to here I am
now let's see beats dina bassem dala
diabetes would be sem icons up to 3 yes here is our either
still cool moliere
found this that debut where at least
some idea is here
probably well, that is, with a heart of 5 potential
want well i'm pissed off just playing to
dress up 1
it is not clear at all what is black
so nice after c5 everyone hits me there
it seems they took it again, you can go
to such beat the elephant do not beat the canyon
try that's what happens that the Tatars
if to play yes and maybe
completely change and assert that here
it's nicer yes kunya 4 where the queen is
baby yes and late 5 there on barely hide ya
I'll lose something here it's my legs entangled
this horse
but nevertheless radiation alone plays and
so to speak the ball is half magus
interrupts yes, they say, decide for yourself if you want
do you c5 do you want e5 to move e5
By the way, it can also be quite legitimate
the idea here is just necessary, probably all the same
here is the answer on horse d5 to have because
that's just got taken gets hit
this is a stupid boat for this and here
it seems black is unpleasant as the owner 6
but maybe on a horse 5 something can be there
no nothing wait a bit and so
getting ready
c5 like this or something
I don't have any interesting closet either.
I'm looking at the old king of course
until I appeared walking 3 but how on
him toss cut out over the area
science fiction I don't seem to
it looks like blacks have a rich active
the game, that is, all the same, it is necessary somehow
or cultivate there to clean the boat
to be 8 to us options and hung yeah
maybe then put the second on c8 well
it seems that after all sc7 c5 will be connected
form
what do you think, for example, on the water at 8 what
who is the head of the kindergarten, well done and I am alone
they want doubles in this position 0 and vd1
were not ruining the model to complete the ec8
so far what next spoil it can
be here already think about think about
move d5 because usually the exchange in
White's favor so if that's not the days
to delve deeply before after e5, well, you need to again
same need to read some options are related
with 3 there is such a horse to be four
an attempt to enter c6 yes, let's say here
there is an opportunity to yawn again
some such tactic
attacked the queen and
11:06 sags that is again
it's possible that it's just that white beats and
reinforce then this horses at the house 4
Well, that is, there are still problems with
world champion in water would be 8 dan
at least 8 plays that the rook did not hang all
yes yes scary can be owns yes
one move empty might be worth it
play from riga to a3 for now, well, somehow
potential struggle with would 4 and support
horse horse would be 4 case options say
found 85 and if black play and sing and
I don't understand that you don't have to
nevertheless, then immediately appears
jump by four to c6
but these positions, well, I don’t know how they are
evaluate with exchange of queens without exchange
queens here feel better for white
need to be in school misfortune with such a b6
and I'll take and you'll take I can take a
why not they took it for what's up to the house
depends on the fact that black 44 even
such a release
it is necessary 666 while maybe and you can I I don't
I know conditionally 206 while I went
I'm up to 84, well, here again something is wrong
she could get stuck 6 to d6 and not
you have time to take from here you can whale
the problem is to bring yourself all the same
fd1 plays deev d1 lags ft-86 while we
guessed about 3 visits for everything
moves in this game and again at the magus
a certain lag on the order clock
five minutes before that is din 21 minutes y
magnus 16
how white to inhabit the position
still as an option there is still a move at the end of 5 here
such there are motives lowered before after
universal
captures as such not d5 let's play
cut off the queen from the knight f6 black almost
not 8 should give queen f8 and say here and
horse quite deserve attention yes and
some position knight f6 goes well 6 yes well
it is clear that only heavy figures are difficult
seriously expect to win but still
less white absolutely full
compensation and maybe even some more
chances of superiority in counterattacks against
Sergey Karyakin did not play and remember
when yes yes sergey miraculously sprinkle pauses and
addition is also in Tibet on here later
blacks retreated
it will be simpler yes, sergey had it there
ditto 6 bruce lee fusing he's already seven
somewhere
so what is this silence it is clear what
determined to a large extent determined by where
further where will the game go until the end
5th move is possible but it doesn't feel like
the strongest can be yes until 23 lol
Yes, you need to check from 5 years old
they took it there if I exchange everything it seems to be
the blacks have your order now they're laden
c5 take now logging 5 take and like
everything would be fine
Might be worth trying again
keep the knight 3 against char
floor well, here it means I understand that in
Catalan quite often caina center
here is the most logical development, let's say
horse for 3 that he is out of work there and even
interferes a little, that is, I think that
white people would be terribly pleased
get rid of this pair of horses if
it was possible if it was possible before
exchange end a3 for knight f6 what is it
would be clearly in favor of whites
here we tried dates 5 here it's true
e5 a3 this was the version and for some reason
Now I realized that seriously
considered to take it may be possible
beat black somehow you still have
get along 6 relevant enough
move c5 seems to me more than
it is doubtful that there is something there
sag down the line da3 plays ding
agreement is found five times there
admiration is 5 he agrees but
you need to understand this to understand how all the same
25 reagents what whites are already creating
a specific threat in particular without a move
up to 5 immediately jump normal but there
suppose some kind of yes knight d4 y
black most likely the problem depends on a6
attacks c6 given c5 magus plays
to c5 dc
beats with a knight one with an elephant takes dan
sun 5 calls 5 now the question is how to proceed
whether to change everything or leave the horse 3
against word c5
Well, here again, here, stand white
the knight is not on c3 but let's say on d2
so that I can play knight f3
thought whites could claim
some small plus
changing to c5 and here the day takes
candida 5 lovecats feeling here again
black must have a scientist
order now let's see anyway
photo 4 here is an attempt
before hooking a pawn knight 2 plays and here
interesting by the way the horse and two on b4 again
the same for magic for the k coupon bullets d3
maybe still some micro
tasks will have to be solved by magnus
let's say play I'm not here again
I'm sure of it, of course I think
what is the position what is close cranus chairs
equal to magnus will have to make a couple
exact moves
even skates 5 why no bitcoins 5 before
then maybe whites can
brush off a couple go get along dandy and
here it may not be possible to leave the center
battle offers d 4 to 6 would mean 6
I was a little afraid that we were four somehow
can cut off this knight jump to b4
domus tver to 4 in the center just stand
it is not clear what to what exchange warm-up not
leads more or less were me
immediately nothing again and grants plays
again, the horse would not let 4
I like on some 5 and 4 what can
be four at once well and in general move
like sensible to the field would be 5 for either
4 covered on b5 not so weak pawns
well, experience teaches that it is almost unrealistic in
such positions black get some
chances yes, that is, it seems to me that here
most primitive pick go rings 1
with your own hand put it on
2 3 yes it seems so difficult to me
show anything at all
maybe a4 p4 this printer is a4 exactly
this edition you are not yet festa 2 has
walker d3 what worries them much
more and if so yes what to change it
even the heart of the two outcomes principle is here already
and change looks good, well, I guess
Yes, they probably get along again 5-ku ns1 this
completely intuitive culture
permutation i think i should have
whites are much more comfortable
friday 5 5 filter back horse on
in the center it will be possible to exchange yes here
depends again on what white
play through d3
we be all the same now would 4 leave
2 for now, but I just wanted it
to avoid
that it seems to me that if black holds
would 4
such an opportune moment and them with a horse on
d5 maybe very 15 to climb c2
through e3 and 1 but he wants
provoke take her on t1 i'm so
I think to take him with a horse after all
translate but inside
here is the question i thought lost weight dress 81
immediately, that is, could immediately 15 1251
really the horse man has already taken the end
one yes horse perry goes to need three
Yes, here it is necessary not to attack the queen in a move
knight d5 because the water is up to 5 the party
ends for a moment it seemed to me
what what here make a move with the pace again
just immediately loses yes and the hall
grandfathers 5 more precisely rosstat figures
hashwa even casino from 7 to 4 years old
and 4 both 4 a4 there some
trained maybe three queen b4 but
again, this is connected with the exact
whether the pawn on a4 is taken by black
if she is a nuisance yes if the dishes are here
i just swap magic 18 wall if i
I want to take I recommend 3
how do you rate this position again
it's hard to say I once won
here is some kind of horse hairpin
so that's conditionally saying something like this
yes it's black again
must play this is very very
obnoxious to blacks why are you even
it's hard to explain why the percentage is 365
there is no stone there somehow immediately the whites run
and at 4 start the king come here and there
mean the problem is there at some point
then say korolev 8 then the king is e7
so here it seems to be possible where it was in
that the king's pawns sag
let's say on the king to 6 what kind of e5
here you can play some 6
there were versions that it was very difficult actually
move as soon as the king to 6 whom
does not jump to e5, that is, even such
less or they are needed already in this
position predator give out before guessing
does the horse hold on sometimes does he hold on
on some nuances
well filmed cd8
[music]
I'm being driven to my feet yet here still here's the moment
18 you can try lags while saving
play d3 in hope of owner one
play but now it will get better here I am c8
now tell baby 11 i want a queen
take yes let's come take can be it
slightly better version
I can not translate
continue walking like this x reach that
there is because f3r myth 2 and 4 that's something
this is what they do, that is, this
the concept is overblown so to speak
give out I don't know how in Russian
called honestly mud here, alas, it was not
such a term, yes, well, that's when you
pushed his pawns too far and did not
not particularly conveniently located for these
pawns defend b5 be four plays
I can also wonder because right away
determine yes look one beats the usual
here it is too
characteristic moment queen b4
it's fun when 3 unnatural kun
up to 3 usually this is just in favor
White if Black does not have time to
clear that as soon as
pawns on the queenside are eliminated
draw 93 volodya one i suspect not so
yes, but now it will be like this until 5
somewhere between an angry grandfather
good four planets . got here
white already before white seems to have already amassed
pawn and step on d1 us king 2 and they
I don't see how it is
yes but it's actually not at all
says that black is playing like that
should well why this position at all
problematic because
adequate parking for horses yes so
say corresponding to one another
squirrels on the children of scientists go where is this
on d5 and here is the knight with up to 3 pawn b2
finally protects up to 5 does not reach
pawns and in the presence of a heavy piece by this
and the spiers are also, again, a little uncomfortable
invoke your own party but
once upon a time it's the difference
here is the minimum hasty structure
also succeeded when such a technical
parties in the game on candida refers to d6 so far
receding magnus is some kind of viscous
move without letting the horse jump yes, well, so I
I understand that the rook is one anyway
perhaps the b5 rook is planned
suspect own wants to lift by
5 driving for 5 is not bad well and understandable
Yes, what is most important, perhaps Black's task is
get rid of horses as soon as possible
changes or either it doesn't even change
just manages to break the end to 3
say
aka 4-ku not 5 is placed before i always
wanted to spend to 5 to 4 change can
be so we here given the fact that the rook
5 rises husband now appears
here's an idea end 4 with tempo and kanye
5 yes you are right horse by 4.5 kanebo 4
also not worse there finally again some
can felix up to 4 answers 115
Well, here's the ding at least getting along canin without attacking
on the pawn a but on the other hand the rook on the c-file husband
be a little more
a little more work to do this
well done and one Magnus almost answered them
4 but almost answered that nikon d5 but now
again if first c5
you are at least alexia or 4 and come to them
everyone is leaving for them and you are leaving, I will give you a lift
I tried this mixture
but i'm right
why is this so I say something
some big advantage for White
that blacks need to find exactly how they are
they hold on
if you played this position with black
against magnus trembled trembled like
aspen
sorry zak aspen leaf but maybe
a beggar would have done that is somehow not here
there is no feeling that there are big problems with
if this is how you end up draw us
waiting endless damn why
endlessly waiting on waiting until two parties
if they are both well, that is, if they exchange
strikes or two draws if the first
proximity end 11 so yeah
the second blitz and then I ask you to notice
magnus heard this approach does not know
correct move in this position okay i
in my opinion there I say that here is the first before
4 can make you a little nervous
and by the way Christ 4 so out of 4
series b6
well, the owners of 525 are hoping for a horse
4 each get 8 shards
it's true that the parties didn't seem to win
after the world only 7 well so scare
you can scare them, they are found 55
Well, in principle, is it possible to knights b4
because you know it's scary
like 4 some more kunge 5 appear
move up to
honestly, there is no complete comfort for black
see if
and finally 4 still go get along 8
a little bit continue the version of the king to everyone
i like it when i have to
weaken, that is, everywhere 46 this one
how do you assess the position, well, it's not difficult
to evaluate it, you still need to understand
there is some can we eat
some kind of crazy people took it like that
yes, not all the bark is only 8 marten 5 well there
like black is holding on to the youth move
81 king same 2 and have to give up
there is no more protection from [ __ ] 6 but it seems to be
holding on to the progress of youth you're not here yet
know depends on if there is eternal
shah no thing on the ears suspect secretly
6 White doesn't lose because
pawns are weak the king is weak if taken on
maybe and attack the pawn wait how
only four times later take 6 on b8 and
kanye piranha
well it somehow continues to play there
sims 2 heart on getting through in 4
korzha shooting g6 won a pawn for example
i wanted cuni 5 com 4 again
transfer but so far shares
don't give let's watch can spa how
ordinary did not go and moreover he went
through b3 that's just something that is this
confrontation unpleasant queen b3 out
the idea for the rook is again to give a chance to take d1
barely
a little bit so the situation escalates I would
said the king 2 calmly a4 a4
introducing quality I don't know how I want
walk on the 24th fret again like me
go on potato here is one moment
this is 4 rooks again the second what is already
some versions appear with e chin and or
give a horse 4 let's say white martens 5
they are going somewhere and urgently while these two
the figures are distracted and turn into some kind of
an attack on the king is also sometimes
happens
although 4 of course
move make wants to learn how to keep it up
wait a minute and then cuba 4 anyway kuni ii
5d
akunina 4 knights 5 in this position 17
105 .
martens this is some kind of ending to take
these two films through d7 apparently and already
there some start matting ideas on
look can we reach for a pawn and what
but at 45 she is not lost, well, for now
doesn't look convincing champions
Russian, I would say that the advantage
rather 1 but such a game yes there is 1
hotbeds world 7 me enough for now yes
well, you know, and right there as soon as you
find an opportunity to change horses
the party is more or less over
there is and there at least minutes remain on the clock
what Magnus has failed so far
get rid of in omsk magical understood yes
trend is serious I liked your move
as sent again I want to protect not
understandable yes I don't want to say play this
position
play this position that's the point here
bc
maybe try like this
health beads course good no doubt
get on your nerves a little
and plus return the queen all the same somewhere on
human cells
sounded like human cells
so through e4 this is most likely not a move
one queen 4 that is me actually
it seemed to me that I do not yawn kuni in 4 for
queens 3 before but here at least you can
just take on e4 on e3 on b2
though such positions ive tried rks
open walk or
Well, ideally, you don’t want to, but here you have to
walk and freeze yes now now already now
this design is much less reliable then
it is now White's task to get rid of
queens and play a role in 2 and 4 crust e3
like this and at the same time
of course not again
the exchange of horses is then quite difficult here
looks like task back here for 6 sit a4
a3 +
aiming pawns barely but can't essence
I like to defend well
Dimka supports me when
the case of the party is very interesting, although it seems
really dry
illustration of Catalan ideas so to speak
about such endings and for whites and for some reason
have now say on the lion king 2
it seems that it is already possible 4 it is not clear how
a3 stop reminds precipitation
martial arts so far on direct contact
nobody and do it king and v2
played yes and it seems like now a4 a3 not
you can see if black plays a4 again
how to stop how to prevent a move
atris full exchange
and dad feeling full from drying and not
quite understandable if there is a big s yet
the king went on why i want to tie
you in it sounded ambiguous there
connected you're coming back yourself just about
owned dress up 8 shahu or not you 4 no
I do not understand why, as they say, to search
from good to good
black 10 find a4 next move away from
3k after your Wednesday playin on
win repeat move party
ends if pawns are exchanged yes then
there is everything in white no
no initiative left
Yes, it seems that it is not visible to stop there
a3 income yi 4k too ambitious will give
although the horse would be 4 to no
by 4 moves no mind what you need her 4k nothing
no rook is lost
b3 i can't get through so do 3 you
you can but she go up to maybe this
I mean, I don't want to
loosen them three or four given
diablo 3 means and here and here
it’s not clear yes, that is, after Kanye 5 already
maybe whites have some problems
arises our just get down on
first knot get dressed 14 well here's an attempt
to exchange all the same queens and wait here
it seems like you can take it and play
radio wuss take play fritters maybe
when the beat manages to eat four types and
the jester manages to hold the tension
can hardly change anything at heart 4
outcome fil for seven tie the rook to
tie get along and repeat stance through
to 4 back like this one ready
ready to repeat position word for
at the same time, this threatens to get along with Magnus
8 so just in case so black has
also very strong reasons that
called dressing up no
probably the development of events tie-break film
for 6 back what ding still think
of course before before inputs
repeat but in general it looks like yes that
nothing nothing stronger for white
is not located and most likely we will be
wait two games in blitz well done and not
found it just funny enough date
releases were different come up with nothing
different options yes here are the owners 4 or
water by 1 comes down to the same
even owning 4 attacked a pawn on the server
black just before sb lost queen
played the queen and actually in this way
solve the same problem
getting rid of the pawns of the queens and the fleet that
let's meet
news do we have any stock
rice for dino movement if for that
script how rex ​​likes to be played
extra long batch toris
could end up in a classic
udino to beat virtually no one
it seems to me that rex would be with
enjoyed following the tournament
us another round of 10 classical chess
so he often sits at the chess
the board next to the cube analyzes the pull
that I'm going down and it looks like the second batch
ends in a draw and so the score is 1 1
now let's find out what color it will be
play blitz yet
referee accepted by lot yes here is the referee
chris bird now I understand we will
find out which color will continue for now
there are no links to the parties, that is, it looks like
[music]
it seems that probably additionally lives to
with help to make you extra
draw but
shape is returned to its original position.
until the clock should show 503 on
every dial to remind that
now us after a short break
will be waiting for a match of two blitz parties
such a long blitz five minutes plus 3
seconds delay and if this match
for the rings in a draw then the match is repeated
repeats again and only then
for some reason I have little faith that everything
still in blitz eats from three attempts will be everything
three times 11 it seems to me that everything is in the face
will decide autumn in the first so in the second well
let's watch together let's break
briefly and back to only players
will be ready to return to the game
[music]
arbat fell
from the brush hare and ball
[music]
zehnder before the dam slide elven
on to the next one wedding
[applause]
pieces through site and ash out of service
[music]
say ryder skill per hour over the edge games
online
emploi rated now club of azov
Argument in fiesta
it's club at lax 1 class lari knows
vat from the game on the table stood birds low land
life
condensate single now cloven this
part I became
[music]
day
well
it would then
money
[music]
but
we
[music]
[applause]
not everywhere the site of the council to worry candles
he was world of tanks kissed the deck i
rental manager tell me
staring is ours but a plus for museums
right and staff
clearly on you and blueberry no praised
give up afraid of computer and knitted
cap from the rules
greasy out of sex tongue with bad
Earl rate him an hour and mother
list
[music]
class a time
online play experience
[music]
so back to fun
tie-break you seem opposite denali
she has two parties 5 plus 3 and in 1 at Dean
again there will be white pieces as well as
previous ones, that is, the order changes
colors in the match it means that before
repeats gives the color of the previous batch
same day
got a taste so like it
comment at all imagine
I can’t how will you live without us
today it all ends so today denmark
Surely everything must come to an end
nowhere to go but look how interesting
Magnus is still not sitting at the board
one at the same fully concentrated
and trying to somehow predict what
what's going to happen there let me remind you
rapid blitz up won
single batch and granule wrapped
Denley Zhenya won in the first round
this statistic is no longer about
what does not tell us because the party then
there is a portion of the match in rapida already finished
11 but the blitz they exchanged victories then
there is a blitz tournament down the street fast was
account 1 1
both won mike weak or white
pieces what level of play does rex have if
it's not a secret
secrets and counting no longer set language
to talk to me it seems he plays on
amateur level 1600
1700 tons often plays ten minutes
15-minute patina on the Internet and yes
it really amazes me how
loves chess in the morning he sits at the board
step at the chess club analyzes
yesterday I found his book and he
preparing vodka match tonight's match
valty rushed and so arrived arrived
magus at the table, as I understand it, the party
will start at any moment and well, not even
know what to expect now repeat k
Coupon either endure if to appeared in
chat
if that's what you think i have no idea
to be honest, the wick, yes, but there sometimes
Evgeniy Virchenko appears while during
our ethers with Peter
there was even no one who called
magnus hanso what i suspect
after all, the vazir parterre and maybe not
the real peter svidler
c4 knight f6 same 3 like this
the party is developing, well, it looks like
permutation of moves can still come to
talonu after d5 true dance played horse
f3
there is a possibility which directory without d4d
dc step so4
candy 7 you know maybe just just
move but already the knight is not on h3 went to f3
yes, I can play asema 64
Kevin wants to go visible the same
landscape 662
and c5 here play up out enough
the fundamental move is a2a 4 in order not to
give all the same five times the horse is put
c3 play very similar character
get a position
that water b8 can immediately yes you can elephant before
6 play here forever question londa 6 or
bishop e7 yes, that is, both of them
input may be some minus and may
whether in this position white is third in such
scheme
3 as far as data, well, that is, what move
blacks do in every salon 7 7 and
just arrange b3 now as a grave
have to still have to go d4
sooner or later right weak 2 well
alright lad 8 i.e. sooner or later
castling b5 is not entirely clear
how much good as if I'm worth you
it is not clear due to what white claims
overweight and moreover if 3d 300
vita horse would like to have must 2
Finally I can't see the wheel
why accounting womb does it have to be like this
significant service problems 7 well
if black succeeds normally
break up like they have everything in general
ok
try to either d4 quickly carry out yes and
the bishop of this enter the code on e3 on m4
after after until 24 either hearts 887 plays
Magnus apparently the idea is to say on
leaving short castling on the rook on
85 b5 b6 even b6 let's say and on the knight and 5
have the answer elephant basi
up to 4
Yes, up to 24 Dean plays, here's another one
discussion in the catalog is waiting for us
what is the difference d4
slates take the knight retreats to b3
and where do you need 6 and 7 on 7 on d6 now
short castling, I think it's black
they castling short, yes, and so
somehow White has a couple of moves to prevent
normal development fd1 hinting that
somewhere it will sag as if up to 6 on occasion
so far enough already
rook b8 looks suspicious
which nevertheless
most likely you still have to do a
what a rather unpleasant situation
turns out and mongoose and time we
forget that there is another one closer
change of scenery at mogu saber minutes and 40
seconds left bishop e5 well leaving
reserve the opportunity on occasion
exchange for citrine scrapped e3 it
lets white play sun three
3 hearts white and of course they want
play endings without saying what's on
sun 3 also some kind of cat get along
one to keep myself and the structure yes
Then
I hope to take on 3 with a queen and a rook
is it good or bad is it necessary somehow
try up try to collect water by 8
the rook marches would be 85 and the bishop on b7 and that's it
here b6 leaves the pawn terrific on
the b6 field itself, yes, first of all, it’s almost a fact
that they have time for black, and if 5 then
the position of the knight on b3 is justified after
b5 the knight on 5 jumps quite often there
you know the feeling that just Magnus is not
called
did not call so very seriously yes that is
you can just get a bad position
40 minutes remain and moreover, the tank is not
can't just sits and can't can't
make a move, that is, something like this
voltage cat stupor such well because
that in a minute this position will be played
just more annoying
did not actually come out of the debut
not out of debut remember delay
just three seconds 5 well right
must twist must twist must
try to somehow change the course of the party
Dean picks up elephant well picked up
took away but now what now probably
how can you beat this pawn, probably how
then you can capture this pawn or just
maybe a radiation one just to play
with the idea to take on d5 with a knight after all
the move itself is such a nice let down
recent resources will give let's say the case
horse f6 some coolpad b-52 appears
captures on f6 bishop and at 6 owners 2 but
after all, White has an extra pawn
what does black have thanks to the cat's two bishops
counterplay is probably there if the chances of
a draw but quite seriously achieved
dead 1 to egg 1 and magnus continues
time to water this this this this
it is completely incomprehensible that nothing is
rearranged you know nothing yet
tuned in to the blitz game in less than a minute
Magnus Carlsen still has the knight f6 yes
well, everything seems to be going to this position here
still need to say that that's practical
viewpoint loading can be nikon
d5 and bishop g4 was a very unpleasant move
exchange Ternopil move, taking into account that
what does Magnus have for a short time yes that's it
I recharge that this is a very insidious move
for a long time, well, they have six wins and 5 5 here
so here - react that clothes water
poke dan
queens seem to have to be changed before
they took on t2 get along 2 and an elephant and at 6 well
what are the options here there are moons 4
there is a comic cube 5.5 until while at
pack this word 108 to
it was impossible to develop villains 8
calmly, of course, the trouble is white will start
somehow the same time wasting the issue of manda
4 bishop e7 it is clear that Magnus does not want
change char outdoor what he would like
probably in some version go to
multi-colored although multi-colored heavy by
in a hurry, well, it’s clear what it feels like
huge chance and absolutely
let's say it's as easy as this city was given
chance of water and 5 water and 5 tying an elephant out
mdf 6 magus 6 plays up owns reno
what a king and everyone needs queens
I can't stand this bunch
it seems that you need to find the king and everyone
up though wait while eat eat with pace
bishop and at 5 then take and on c5 can
to be this one Magnus needs to do before
unbelievable, yes, I thought about it
barriers at five, like at 5, well
the rook is retreating somewhere;
still a chance to save a couple
elephants anyway
I have to take you in time for us
takes on c5 because this knight
it is virtually impossible to endure, well, plus
25 seconds left is easier to play
still the same color
it's easier to play different colors than to save
opportunity to play 34
give no, I understand that multi-colored
far from no man's yet what else suffering
there's a serious one to decide
it is in this position to think to find
the most accurate move because of
theoretically you could play now
queen d3
do not give white, that is, do not give black
go to multicolor so water 2 to elephant
beats c5 bishop bc5 it is clear that but no you can
and 8 to exchange, that's why the day
think that after all he has two options
take on c5 or exchange on and 8
decides to take on and 8 immediately gave 18 cm
dc5 well done 8 immediately yes it seems to me
the worst is still behind the moment but
b4 here that we get rid of one pawn
again we play until a5 a3 took took and
owners 7 environment where is your grandfather this
play well white by the standards of f3
water up to 7 rook in an understandable way
changes the rook for 2 leaves as much as 7 h5 to the role
in two kings to everyone, as he said very much
a nasty defense awaits magnus but
I objectively suspect that the position is no longer
chain that black should hold on to the move
rook to 8 b5 this is interesting
solution
but in principle it is logical to install b5
slate 4 where she barely attacks really
the champion will save it of course
seems really money got nervous
I didn't expect that I didn't expect that like this
around only good got huge
preponderance debut they are the same
you need an overweight on the clock and magna
accompany very little time and feeling
that cheapened yes because now
it is not at all clear how
how to continue the game at all
win if black just keeps holding on
by 6, that is, by 7 to the water to 3 check, well
interestingly now there is a transition to
a counterattack there, the mouth does not seem to bypass
three promotes water can be worth it
start coming off the king the same wool is not the same
the waste goes away rolls back Magnus
water to 7 well 4 try the same 4 took
take the king put the pawn our 5 here
something like this
king and 5 will threaten checkmate in 1442
there are two of us at once, maybe there are some
there is shaxov 8 support everything is fine and so
wait, what is there to take a feather bed and h5
shaxov 8 is by the way very dangerous and even
the check does not give a pawn beat on the same 41 king
and everyone on seconds Magnus 10 seconds
it remains to be accelerated it remains to be accelerated
believes that this is a position I did not
does he take something i think she has
just don't have time to
think about what took and the king took and what
threatens a mate in 1 move live 8 that is, it is necessary
add5 scarf play undoubtedly king
departs on the water for 1 well well then
5 then 5 so step step on and everyone
back must walk here and not sure about
one apparently thought that to drive the king
do you need something
owns 860 and a and king same 5 passes
king 5 you go through flash drives to everyone
won won I think white
objectively just a won position then
there's now somehow you need to check the king on
same 8 let in vain let the king go in vain
now will I go on all the water to 5 shah
island and
discards the king true hanging pawn would
5 moments elephant up to 35 cm up to 35 already 6
mud
I think that absolute grandfathers won 86
no it's the winning position of the sun 4
some kind of you with the king of our 8 elephants
our 80 and before whether it is necessary to translate
can't you just play the words hp a6
a6 checker role he so through shorter again
to torture it is clear what will be the step played
back hardest hardest position y
magnus and and time perfectly from the moons to
6 such an insidious honda 6 transition to e5
that the king is the same 5 can be calmly up to the king
g5 officiating no 5 play servants 5 plays
Zindana h5 must be taken, no doubt, well
what now first knives to everyone or the king
the same 5 can be on the weights of queens 8 elephant
like this first intermediate move king
same 5 servants 2 la hold 7 shah retreats
water and everyone seems to have already found victory
Dean got really fast
no look struggling struggling elephant
returns on c4 before the bishop returns 24
keeps the pawn in this way
well, now you need water d1 and become
behind
become why really keep well
of course yes because victory
so close
check on e7 lag a7 so we are all now
of course now you need to put the rook behind
passing king e-8 still does not let a
this Magnus made a mistake king h8 check
get at least 7 back very hard
wait still yes here we don't want rooks 1
catalog 13 triple repetition was
that's interesting, I don't know if it's possible
demand but there was a message one was
repeat three times and here and there
triple repetition of us goes like this
wait what happens rook
eight planets up to 8 can drive away the king
very far korolev 8 prefers gays
2 before have to come back have to
back now on same up rule dune
keep on the same king unfortunately kicked out
far to the nest 65 did not even want to camp
5 that I can attack there 15 deceit
what to give if there was chess here
holding magnus holding position king to 6
then will it really hold up
fiction
so once again repeat the king a6 and that
check the king is all three times
another three times, well, here it is
awkward moment because I can do something
more he lost that time
incredible
i can't help it i think a couple
once per game was three times
repetition of moves now if text
will appear, we will definitely check it
Well, Denley wins the first game
doesn't mom know
about what can be demanded three times
be now wait now
100 forces are not here, I'll try somehow here
find all the same this moment king e-8
served weaker one here in my opinion
here yes i.e. king h8 check and
returned it once the water would be seven
rooks from Volodya and seven rooks one
exactly repeated three times
position and more four times
repeated this position and closer to
the end for my second time was
triple repetition at this moment
owns it the king up to 6 owns the records
wall role a6 check and that was also
triple repetition by ambassador up to 4
Magnus just overstayed the time, that is
missed two chances to claim
three repetitions of moves to
the return game will start very soon
so I understand literally through
three or four minutes and I can need more glorious
only victory to continue
fight for the cup of hay trying not to
scream but it doesn't work very well
worry about how hard it is
play such parts in time
that we are waiting for us in 5 minutes
[music]
[applause]
they're here all right to troops us from
blues
world of tanks or tell about a lubil
the manager will already be with the lease with each
language idea plus given
start the blues vision 1 to
[music]
complex via
san luis aliexpress
[music]
2 of 5
this is him while i was in urfa xango close ad
irrigator
towel
however, flowers from the miz bolshunova
vkontakte
yes there will be shopping
new and old as a half life in florence
and a place on the agent smith disk
like steel and nicole the rack itself
I am a python 3 five
without you like this ditches withers funds
facts so now lawrence
from the basics at all its valuable match killed
match could fans now shared clothes on
wammy pedal does one over the mee jump
he goes to the scene where to get so mnoy this he
is
fell baby oh my god your shroud and skills
and trends
my quality of life is just him
downhill jam and if what a crisis
width experience in the final
[music]
azov films and current
abloy oy.
we are now
les enfants
enough like the world
soil
from world of tanks in space police in
world politics
artex aim reported at hour art and
design whom i exhibitions and linen in
real-time
from it by the way tiny love
mr craven
jumpsuits now you image
live my cup pool who's better
as hell hour dough cake
[music]
well, such a dramatic first
party blitz and we look like ready for 2 not
I know if I'm ready for the second batch of magnus
carlsson white to him
try to level the score before in this tournament
we've already seen feats from magnus
yeah, let's see if it works
another feat, well, what do you need to play
don't even know me gas in the first place
we have to play faster we already had
precedent
return the flag of the selected position against you
we will also cut the forests before my eyes and not
I know you need to get together of course with me
hands are shaking
how so e4 e5 nf3 nc6
and Spanish so what will happen
play something
one very hard some surprise someone
not neighbors with up to 3 that's probably
right yes i.e. don't don't give
forced to try to play some
play it faster yeah play it faster
obviously learned this lesson you told me
what is the most important thing to play at all
fast to blitz especially the only ones
vida dice to the exception must be played
fast now 1 hour refrigeration
ending such a small stone in
I don’t remember the garden, but not that
it's not that my son didn't understand what
that yesterday's party is certainly for a long time
leave a residue like that, well, as much as three water
and 8 to a more theoretical position so
I understand from trying I think that Dean wanted
most likely to play some kind of marshal
houses and after after the move d3 yes that is
d3
moved into something like this very
Chigorin's so-called variant
from time immemorial 55 to where where black has just not the same
strange hybrids 5 like smoke goes horse
c3
in general these just bring the knight to b6
so they are big somehow queen d8 bishop before
8 cm this one, well, that is, like 8 before so
wait Magnus played from the moon 3 are getting along
8q not 2 give me seems to give though for now
probably while making an elephant and you don't
put bishop up to 8 g3 islam b6 white
Kim will react with a lunge sun 5
they will try something there on the royal
create horse bassem retreats ding probably
m this interesting yes because would 4
Magnus is not ready to be anywhere 4
normal reaction of course on campus
over the usual here again, and a3 white is not
had time so after cuba 7 the same 4
5 rings are played and the knight takes 31
you need three calmly and such that 4
service 5 somewhere you can mark b4 yes here
as if b5 is a position for black, I think
absolutely normal queen b5 queen b5 in
hope to exchange queens, it’s clear that yes
it will be a huge achievement and it looks like
that the white queen has nowhere to run first d1
first c4 hearts two of income no
owners of 7 control spike or in 5
money decided to stay ananda here that is
owners 7 2 11 8 that magnus somehow
gotta get to the king of other chances
in this party no ah do it for now
more than not just already 5 at Comic Con
moves away to hangs on h3 maybe the same 5
oddly enough u gotta go conditional
3 still plays nitrile dress up 8 but
White has less and less time
here is such a d2, that is, here they get along 2 will be
met b3 villas and finally 6
black play leak this horse same 3
before i.e. there is no more jump on from 5
probably need to lubricate probably need to
queen f3 there the problem is that the bishop is the same
5 I think after the queen in 3 will be the same
unpleasant that in response to serve 5
black horse up to 5 years
wipe my picture will play again
although to take and now spare parts are already somewhere
jump to 3 judges to put all the same
knight on c4
here Magnus manages to understand even the party
which must be played strictly to win
somehow manage to save save
you don’t know the human form in general
don't go like this all forward like this
this is a reckless takada, but somehow keep
up hold position so queen b7 but what
here there is some scary horse
fate 5 horses again such a jump street 4
scrap b5 played on a knight again and vodka
again, oddly enough, very stable
will stand well, including up to attack
while on the pawn there the bishop is 5 somewhere
prepare queen d8 black retreat yes
via d2
attacks the pawn d4 and puts 3 which
i.e. honda
that's how it plays and that's how it plays
din
dress 3 here it’s not clear what to do
because they have already outlined the black queen ec7
cruiser visited a 23 a 23 on take
windows 4
I take the quality I don't know but no I don't
I take away qualitatively be the mode inhabited
on bahts hangs well a3 at least
up to baladeo 3 playable
we secure the knight's parking again the knight c6
picks up quality no 6 picks up
quality is another question there and plays
magnus late 6 another question what
black may well find compensation
for this quality get along 36 and then
elephant yes will hang on and 4 but in general
we have a game we have here that is all these
fears that Magnus is simply nothing
will get out of the debut and fall apart they cherries
turn out to be so unjustified
take bishop on queen c3 take on d5 here
there is also such a way, by the way, maybe
he is stronger to take on c6 with his bishop
after heart 3 pick up on d5 and pick up
fails on b3 and would have one for lags
the device on the filter can be a queen
that is, mine was mine was some kind of idea
this is such that this position is more likely
total holds became 16 for white extra
quality on a note and somehow very so
it's draped down to black but here's to
it looks like we will come now yes then
have take and bishop wool c3 bishop to 5
already played, well, here it is important of course
correct and choose a square for queen a
e4 pawn
we are also sorry
moved yes most likely through d3 and
because the e4 pawn is undoubtedly a pity
but wait, queen 5 and layered 4g 5 here
the same very, very brazen attempt
select
material then can queen 5 move just
good that is and blacks wish they could
retreat to the pool and shot
also extinguishes well on e4
protects in 3 3 to 5 naturally in 3d 5
moreover, then on 3 white do not pick me up
I suspect that the number would be 7 such
cold running is quite in place
all the same, of course, I want to need us
bounced back and sold continues
happy tie-break
but so far there is no objective reason
I see honestly
what objective reasons do I have in
mind in order to objective
premises of his own milk servant 34
yawned 5 or or we are something earthly fun
2 3 4 so what what after same 5 what after
same 5 even this is an extra rook sorry
that is, apparently like 8 same 5 like 8 you
can you imagine what an attack
on attack on the same 2
well king king and vogele there again
just a hungry man
wait or or calmly get along 2
now yes no queens alone is something not
not there
it's 6 that's right via beta 6
he hangs honda 5 words 7
like seven so don't do me
to change to exchange you can already ferris would
7 is it just that one doesn't want to change i
I thought that queen b7 was taken they took there
on the 5th floor there should be order no
this heart goes well, it’s logical with this
weakened king with the threat of kuni in 4
logical of course report ation one
black all take king h2
it's unbelievable that there will be no march
Isn't there an elephant here? 5
up to 3 5 tons and do not serve 5 through d6 and there
he wants to give check to pick up the elephant maybe I
want servants 3 threaten not 3 hail sun
six exact move because threatened
servants 3 well, you need to pick up 3 of course
Yes
pick up over refers to stock exchange 5 beats magnus
Bishop 6 is needed and Bishop 4 c5 threatens mate
knife about this horse this brilliant resource and
mate threatens our cause which has no protection
and it looks like this Magnus yawned
brilliant move to her all completely
just in my opinion a brilliant move kuni to all
defending break 6 magnus yawned that
they protect everyone from both threats and moto
to f8 and
33 elephants in 3 well there scarf c2 all the same
it's all it's falling yes rather no all
victory-victory denali is not well well
brilliant played tie-break cars
I am a chess player, just below the code is like this on
there were no five arrows either, I suspect
what about it was just bad white already
I suspect that it was bad for white already before
united relaxed surrenders surrenders
magnus carlsson victory 20
in blitz and din
life becomes a cup winner
sentsova is just like that
fantastic denouement to the second just
brilliant and brilliant tactical resource
let's look at this again
already happened before i.e. at the end after
queen beta 3 here is this moment we still
seen on our demo board
Elephant 5 was played as I understand it
Magnus went to that position to take in and out
moon at 4 well now threatens more or less
any jump of a horse with a checkmate is our one and yes
here are the slates 5 move that would win
party because the elephant hangs and threatens
checkmate with queen 8 comes after knight 7
white is forced to surrender because the knight
on the same 3 is pinned and there is no defense against the h1 rook
checkmate well and here on the move and at 3 I'm like this
I suspect at least
it's got board horse at 5 got take it on
f3
threatened, too, but like this most often
i.e. elephant 1 here too
dress up 2 wins zombie g3 wins
queen, I suspect that I'm like a person
cynically, I would take 3 knives, just this one
position would continue to play what do we
very exciting tie-break
applause is heard on the sidelines
it seems the day is invited to the studio
our American colleagues in the blog
owns here let's hope you
will come to the Russian studio deen movements
what can we remember again?
how did the sen hele goblet end yes
you can see the general table
talk about how it turned out for someone
this tournament yes, well, here is the first place
in fact the day can't scarce she doesn't
earn exactly the same
number of points credit grant hour tour
this 17 + 15 halved by sixteen s
half points and not a day
earns $15,000 more
than magnus in this tournament
yes and we have a tour table once again we
we can look at the table
grandis tour after the first tournament on
to my who does not win magnus in
this year the onion soaked
I take ezalora fedor lits and didn't win
that's not won the cup sen here though
did everything to make it happen
here are the prize money, yes, there are three
we have a person on 6 digits
earned up to exactly 100 thousand prize money
maxim in grand frequent 132 and with tenths
denly is not more than 200 already 205 thousand
dollars received for only a foreign hour
tour apart from others and the magnus tournament
cars speed them nazis will get
prize money like you not a consequence like you
do you think the prize fund will increase
next year
I don't know this already this year
as far as I know, the prize fund has been increased
for Saint Phil cup and for tournaments
zagreb yes that is this prize fund
was a record and so
speculate maxim
so a little bit wrong
number of tournaments because it's understandable
that maxim is already all five maxims 5131
movements 3
he played in paris i didn't play for him
Promise not the Count of Abidjan and he played in
in general, a little confusion with the quantity
played tournaments for this column
probably not worth paying attention to
my world is already all messed up in my head and I
I can say that this is very strong
confused the situation in the fight for the fourth
place because there you see three
a person has exactly the same
number of points and taranenko torn
Karjakin is a point behind, I don't remember
still on the stick off i on vichy anand on
bald patch of katanands from the forest and they all have
just in my opinion remains
the only tournament is Aronian even
three days which should be two tournaments
Accordingly, Voronin, I would say that
best odds though distribution system
these credit points such that let's say in
two tournaments finishing in the middle
tables you will get less than
dino winners
personal one stage some look
calendar of future tournaments
upcoming tournaments edge hour tours
it's november we're talking about november yeah that's 4
11 it will be like this in the same format
rapid and blitz in romania bucharest
we are not the capital and from 20 to 27 November
last qualifying tournament
grand hour tour tata steel india dan too
rapid and blitz and final 4 to 4
selected final tournament in london
will play from 30 November to 10 December jenny
you will probably comment
tournament in romania we will be back in
the air will already be to rub the tournament in india
and in london yes it looks like someone yes
will be different
dro will have me another partner on
Romania, yes, but the end of November and the beginning
December we will be in the same composition that we are waiting for
we are probably waiting for dinov studio yes there is
hope to talk to the movement i guess
that there is no point in discussing the party
just a few words from
the winner what it means to me here
it seems that winning the tournament is important, but also
here to win a tie-break with magnus
carlsena this is something special
on the eve
Candidates tournament qualifiers match and even
garry kasparov said what he thinks
movement as if the main contender
perhaps not so, that is, very serious
cut idol yes because and fabi
mentioned
mentioned Harry Kimovich to you can understand
that fabi yes maybe everything just
even when fabi plays we are not brilliant
we all understand how it is
how strong is a chess player and
how dangerous is he and in the first place
tournaments such as Olya tournament
contenders to whom the fabia has time
get ready he doesn't play all these
selection by the way, Dean can also not play in
selections, he took away the whole glade
he was selected by rating while in the tournament
applicants 2 guaranteed participants
this one moves and and fabiana kro jenya
look at the first batch of something to me
suggests
till stay showing us most likely
earth life will have you well what do you
suggests
no the first park is good there is already some
there was an interesting idea with the park on
was it in the eighties and
despot in the eightieth year
the king needs 7 new difficult where is
because you see the idea with padme I don't see
through the king stood knives 80 stood at the same 8
but here but I don't quite understand how
there should have been an idea from to there
because
that we analyzed it so quickly
position is not dissimilar
I don't know if if they will give some more
more accurate so to speak more accurate
information because I was just thinking about
so that black can have actions
sweat ideas yes but but it doesn't look like poison all
I still think Magnus is very good
protected what's here in this first blitz
the party was important that two times Magnus did not
demanded three times twice Magnus didn't
demanded three times what is there
some look at 75 80 comes
some weird idea
after all, with dino saloon d3, that's it
ship 6 6 see what how even when
grandmaster mischenko yawns he yawns
competently, that is, I spoke slando 3 you
I was told no by rook d5 losing a piece
everything is natural but absolutely correct
you told me, well, the other is like the other
the problem is that the whites are playing serve five
parties it goes on it's not that
it's a move possession do not fix
grandma is very beautiful of this trap
very beautiful, but if you play a rook
d5 king e6 then maybe already wins
no no 5 king to 6 body hold five
let's say yes, we stop this pawn
at least we stop here, it seems yes the king
have we keep an elephant it fails her
for life and the king a6 waiting for everyone
the king of all checks can be this and
the draw was just beautiful of course
idea thank you very much
i think mage on most likely to do
well, it was already not up to fat
before but here it still does not give me
rest thought that really double not
demanded not demanded three times
well, you see, even the magician loses his head
seems to just forgot forgot about that
you can demand nothing in person just
the rest of the clock from fixing nothing well
maximum what to add dima time
quite forget all the same very important
it was certainly a strange decision such
yes because i doubt it
I didn't understand what it reminds me of
this situation is triple yes that is
can be insecure style three times not
repeat three times although there in a row on
in fact, that is, it does not happen, you know
such intricate repetitions when there
reappears after ten moves
opposition after a series of maneuvers you can
get it wrong here it just happened three times
in a row so what
let's go for a break and come back with a ding or
he will show up at any moment i bye bye
no information of course worth asking
some questions for the winner
the winner of the tournament but she's there in my opinion
we are leaving all the same for a small one
little pause break and back in
studio life multiplication well then
talk to the winner and move on
actually turning to goodbye
and the end of our show tonight yes
stay with us, we'll do our best
talk to dean lie
[music]
don't escape eight zeus
from the brush site and start
[music]
new organ slow down dark black and
white light ms sql
he is so who the peoples of the earth suffered deliver
[music]
tight cut secrets call of exploitation
Maria and saucy lable hour seal the game
to employ
now club phase form webmaster
handbag water flowed battle ax 1 class
with lari knows
online casino countries has become glorious birds
play candi they quite eye hour cloven
strong man created
[music]
as we will
to the sea and saucy lava hour seal the game
plan and larry
rated now club of already shape we
promise oh stephanie
handbag she so lava taxi 1st class with
lari knows and
[music]
well, in our studio the winner of the cup
singh & field one you congratulations
by line to choose to see we are looking for
cafe fusion and the wench of his son take you down
the dallas everything to order and an aspen leaf
and magic money filter or such a dream and
day says of course this idea is not
he saw when he went to the water and 5 he
wanted to fly hold five will promise
I see where forsoisson read if to the mixture
date likes then hands five handing life than
you'll not be blood face off day out
you sochi
fantastic match here mount rose lady
sings runaways my delphi when games
magnus turnout AIDS
network is only people say this
daniel even a hare can
Spaniard fight and over
paint over only one maidenhair like this
[music]
sometimes quiet
means underestimated says what he thought
Magnus is the favorite in this match because
that he defeated Magnus in all tai
breaks that he played with one
if you give 2007 magnus just
won all tiebreaks and very well
prepared he wanted to avoid some
debut surprises for him was very
important and it is not easy sometimes appear
you decided to give him a frequent capote new family
species
and the wider the sense of the company media
having myself all the dolls quite and
see going
a place of power who supports the day
movement of course family friends of all
matiz you are on the team with which they are together
play and of course friends who are here
present and and asked one decided whether
they have problems with rice they found of course
the same forest near and they cooked every day
for him it is very important with what hephaestus
want to kill mobility sun windows
battalion commander in this tense but saturday june to
stay on ms you and blade
you would like adding
play in the world cup despite the fact that
he has already been selected for the candidate's candidate with this
slovakia and seeing iphone play a thing
get it
basket case and where format to bypass
himself there senate bold
day thinks that the world cup is very important
tournament and he just likes to play it
it has absolutely nothing to do with the cathedral in
he just wants the Candidates Tournament
win the world cup
powder biologists multiple attack tomorrow
gold media weddings in the winx hour with this
monsters and under was smart the note
let him understand and start with her 2k install
flight vodka
my way everything was fishel events
and my way is one let's go gold to above and
asked one motion about how
covered by the media
this tournament and will it be tomorrow
many articles have been published on his victory
said it would most likely
be covered only on the Internet because
what is this private tournament and means
media in china pays
more attention to the official soup tournament
fine-tuning I’ll come up to the olympiads
that means the world chess cup
World Chess Olympiad
command and
and the Candidates Tournament wall your match
in an interview at gdc you're going to read
how i go on this server .
avanti celebration hamdan and go to the end
let's move the plane early in the morning
have to postpone a little celebration and
he hopes to celebrate victory in this
tournament with friends wall soaked
congress life insurance agent in key
[music]
Well, it's time to say goodbye
I see
our work in this studio is suitable
end
st field cup tournament is over
winner
so to speak meetings for grew up to expressed
we can imagine our feelings that
say on the devastation after such
tense tie-break and yes of course and
I feel sorry for Magnus in this situation
brilliant totally played dean
movement second party especially
impressed well, what do we have it seems to me
all the information that could be given to
goblet sendhil ladies in general, then we
We may recall that in the following
principle here in the club betting never
does not cease such a network in
up to
the course of chess life continues yes
that is, we mentioned at the beginning
september 2 or something september starts
fischer chess tournament
here is the same showdown and where is harry
Kasparov will play and I think Peter
svidler play generally enough
interesting, by the way, taking this opportunity
I apologize to Peter Veniamin Chew
which I suspected means that
that it's not him, but just now
exchanged messages like
really it was petya in the chat
so I would like to
to thank you
for your attention for your kind words for
your participation in the chat for me it was
such a commentary debut along with
Eugene I hope you like it
how the terminator will finish the dump be back
in message to English audience
anyway, I would like them anyway
warn here and here I'm in very up to
sling thing you learned where you were
refusal to become become in from the chains of the andes and
inter denetsya konstantin yes and we have them so
I understand that her Russian-speaking audience
might be interesting to see here
the very same kitsch format that
whether yes what such absolutely serious but
nevertheless tournaments altai throwing with
in which teams take part
chess players are mostly made up of
participants of the sinful cup and in each
team has a special
special google is rex himself his son
randy give these teams are playing now
between each other in hurt ten minutes later
put steam rex shots of the field or
act and I think I hope well in general it is
will be broadcast in English
channel
Russian channel to resume broadcasting
from 4 if I remember correctly November to
from 4 to 10 I will still not know with whom
as partners comment on romania
quick blitz yes if worlds back
towards the end of november india quickly and
blitz plus the final tournament in london on
what about new meetings
it was very nice to comment and
always glad to see you
[music]
happens